normally I recommend uh either a film or
a book or a website or something like
that today I want to recommend to you a
particular article it's quite a long
read I read it over the course of
several nights the name of it is
whatsoever things are true by Matthew
share and it's in Atavist this is such a
fascinating story Louis about a killing
that took place in the early eighties
one man initially went to prison for the
killing that man ultimately exonerated
another man went to prison for that
killing his confession ultimately thrown
out and you have a situation where two
men have been convicted of the same
killing neither is now in prison and the
it is I can't even get into the detail
the research done by Matthew share in
this article is fantastic and I couldn't
recommend it more highly and it you know
have been watching making a murderer
which you've now started watching we've
done a lot of stories of exonerations
and and false accusations and and all
sorts of criminal justice uh abortions
for lack of a better term and this
article is really if you're if you're at
all interested in any of that if you
listen to the first season of cereal
you're into making a murder etc read
this article whatsoever things are true
by Matthew share fascinating stuff i
mean just an incredible story yes those
all of those stories about i I guess you
could call miscarriages of justice yeah
in the United States either just too
many they're they're just so many and
yet some more fascinating than others
check out all of my recommendations at
david pakman.com slash recommendations